I do not know what I appears from
the world, but to my so it seemed,
I've only been like a boy
playing on the seashore indef,
rooting myself and now and then finding
a smoother pebble or pretty show than
ordinary.
While the great ocean of truth
lay all undiscovered before me,
Sir Isaac Newton was born on Christmas
Day 1642 it will store Lincolnshire
England.
He is regarded by many to have been the
greatest scientist who ever lived due to
his contributions to physics, mathematics,
optics, astronomy, and many more fields.
His book philosophy and not Rally Spring
Cubia Mathematica and mathematical
principles of natural philosophy
is regarded with equal esteem.
Newton also spent much of his time with
religion coming the Bible for hidden
meaning and with alchemy attempting
to find the philosopher's stone.
Newton was born at three months after
his father had died, was named after him.
He was born prematurely.
Ms Not expect to live but live.
He did as the age of three newtons.
Mother left him to live
with his grandmother and she
went to live with Newton's
new stepfather, angered Newton greatly.
Newton's early education began.
At the king school in Grantham until
those mother widowed again. I'd returned.
She brought him home the farm,
but Newton would return to school becoming
a top of his class and becoming well
known for his accomplishments and his
inventions and 1661 he was admitted to the
Trinity College at Cambridge.
It was here where he was educated in many
sciences and many mats and here where
Newton invented calculus and 1665
okay.
It was also here that the famous falling
apple incident occurred leading Newton
to his discovery of gravity.
There was no books revealed.
He was already thinking of the subject.
Newton left Cambridge and 1665
is a great plague of London,
which killed 25% of the population broke
out return in 1667 it wasn't 1667 also
that Newton became a fellow of trinity.
Though this position required new and
to become an ordained Anglican priest
privately,
Newton had ideas that religion which
would have likely caused him trouble if
publicized.
He did not believe in the trinity and
often scour the Bible looking for hidden
meeting as aforementioned.
Apparently Newton deciphered that the
world would end in the year 2060 but there
was no evidence to support this claim
for these reasons which Newton never
revealed. He avoided the position with
special permission of Charles a second.
Newton's work with
optics was also profound.
He worked with prisms and
explore light and color.
Discovering that white light be
split into many other colors.
He also invented the first
reflecting telescope.
I replacing a lens with a mirror.
Many of his optical discoveries
were putting his book optics.
Newton let a private life.
You're not going along with a few other
scientists of his day and could not
stand criticism.
He was so struck by it that he was
reluctant to ever publish anything much of
its work also would have
been dangerous to him.
It publicized there's
religious explorations as well
as exploration of alchemy.
Newton searched heavily
for the philosopher's stone
and spent much of his time
on alchemy that regarded
as a pseudoscience. Today.
Newton's undertaking of alchemy seems
to resemble more so an early form of
chemistry.
In 1669 Newton you came to the carry
and professor of mathematics a position
more recently held by Stephen Hawking.
Years later in 1679 Newton regain an
interest in astronomical matters while
corresponding with scientists
such as Robert Hook,
John Flam steed and Edmund Holly.
Holly would later help.
Newton published his
Principia Mathematica.
This book stated Newton's laws of motion
and gave birth to classical mechanics.
It was published your life.
Fifth,
1687 years earlier in 1676 Newton
wrote the hook if I have seen farther,
it is by standing on the shoulders of
giants and 1689 and in 1701 Newton became
a member of parliament is recorded
that he only spoke once to,
I said a window be closed.
In 1696 he became warden of the Royal
Mint where he heavily cracked down on
counterfeiters.
Newton held this position for the last
30 years of his life prosecuting 28
corners and 1703 Newton became president
of the royal society and 1705 Newton
was knighted by queen and hence
the name Sir Isaac Newton. Well,
this was likely more due to political
occurrences and scientific achievements
towards the end of his life.
Newton lived in cranberry park with his
niece and her husband until he died in
his sleep on March 20th,
1727 he was buried in Westminster Abbey.
He died of natural causes,
though examinations of his body after
his death revealed traces of mercury in
his hair,
mercury poisoning.
He may have been a part of Newton's
strange behavior and mental breakdowns in
his later life.
The life of Isaac Newton was extremely
profound and the words of Alexander Pope,
I remember it as a suitable
description of Newton
nature and nature's laws.
Late, hidden night, God said,
let there be Newton and all was light.